all right I am holding an impromptu in
between the holidays philosophy pop up
looks like the Internet is a little bit
slow here so you might see a little bit
of glitching back and forth they already
got a couple people who've joined up so
I've got a little bit of time on my
hands before we head off to shutup and
right here in Milwaukee which if you're
not familiar with it's exactly what it
sounds like everybody sits down shuts
the hell up for an hour and then writes
and then after that we get to chit chat
about what we're doing because otherwise
people don't get much writing done at
writing groups so my my kids are here
for Christmas break we've got a today
and tomorrow and then I Drive them back
down and their mom picks them up on
Sunday and we're doing a few things
today we've got a new game that we're
gonna play which was over there I can't
see the title of it but it's supposed to
be quite interesting we already did some
Catan and some Rick and Morty watch the
episodes that we've been waiting to all
watch together did our opening stuff
we've been to the pool a couple of once
we're going again tonight and then
tomorrow as well that's kind of a
holiday tradition for us going back to
the days of when I would get them when
they were quite young and we'd stay in
hotels here in Wisconsin because we were
still living in New York and then we'd
be swimming and looking out at the
snowfall and stuff like that so I don't
really have any particular topics in
mind other than this this sort of weird
time in between the the holiday season
where you've got like you know all the
Christmas festivities and New Year's and
some things are open and some things
aren't you know for example we went to
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
yesterday just to check my mail and it
was closed up so few people chiming in
and saying hello hey
everybody wherever you happen to be in
the world right now I was gonna chat
with one of my my Australia and
colleagues earlier today and find out
exactly what the deal is with Boxing Day
but didn't meet up with him so that's
not a thing that we we do but we've been
doing a lot of cooking here and just
hanging out enjoying our time together
we've been to the Milwaukee Museum a
couple times which is a few blocks down
that way and we're gonna go again later
today what else have we got planned
probably play Catan again before we we
head out we always bring the Rick and
Morty games along with us on the road
because if we stop in somewhere we've
got some time to kill we can we can play
those and those those are quite fun not
too much else going on my dad is coming
up to visit tomorrow and we'll do our
Christmas with him the LEM Rees family
Christmas is happening next weekend when
most of the people can actually get
together and yeah that's that's really
about all the Christmas stuff that's
going on shortly I'm going to leave as I
was mentioning for shut up and right at
the top of the hour and get some work
done for stoicism today and and I owe a
little writing to somebody who's doing a
compiling a bunch of hot takes I've got
a hot take maybe I'll tell you about
that in just a few minutes because it is
it is very much a hot take but in a very
scholarly way what else do we have going
on I have a client appointment for
philosophical counseling there's always
you know some people who are kind of
blue over the holidays as well so a lot
of holiday greetings from people that's
very nice including some that look like
they're perhaps in Cyrillic or something
uh here's here's a question for me so
I'll answer a few questions that I'll
tell you about my hot take connect says
have you read the case against reality
Don Hoffman I haven't but I actually
hand the book because I have a a client
who when he reads books and he reads a
lot of books he boxes them up and sends
them to me I guess he must have
particularly good recall and so he's he
sent me that book and I'm gonna take a
look at it it's up on my my shelf
people are saying hope you had a happy
holiday it was it was a good holiday
Proform has a good question
have you any advice for dealing with
failure yeah expect it yeah this is
something that I talk about probably you
know we meet for the Milwaukee stoic
fellowship once a month and I end up
talking about this probably every other
meeting that I'm there when people say
oh I'm trying to do this and it's not
working and I said well it's like going
to the gym you know when you first start
out you're you're looking around at
everybody else and they're lifting all
these weights or doing these exercises
you know like when I go to a yoga class
I'm watching people doing these these
movements almost flawlessly and I'm
huffing and puffing and my shirt is
falling in my face as I'm doing downward
dogs I forgot that you need you know
sort of tight-fitting things and nothing
is nothing seems to be going right if
you stick with it when it comes to those
sorts of things you fail less but you're
still gonna fail you know I I still lose
my temper and that's something that I've
been working on for years and years but
that's something that I have to work on
particularly and I you know I get I get
sad myself sometimes it's reasonable and
sometimes it's it's unreasonable as a
reaction to things and so you do fail so
you should you should plan to fail and
you shouldn't you know shouldn't allow
yourself to become overly anxious about
it like oh when's when's the shoe gonna
drop when when is the grand fail you're
gonna happen because that's not going to
help you but you do want to be you could
say
and you know if you are paying attention
to what's going on around you
rather than being all locked up in your
own head you will fail less as you see
things that are like danger signs you
know a great example this is when you
have kids you're especially when they're
very young you're constantly alert to
what they're what they're going to knock
over you know and spill and and screw
things up with I guess this applies to
certain kinds of pets as well so by
being attentive to your surrounding not
an obsessive neurotic way but just you
know in a paying attention to things way
it can it can help out as well thoughts
on Spinoza this is from Conrad concept
of God and understanding emotional
causality well I don't think Spinoza's
concept of God I mean I I like I like
reading Spinoza
I rarely teach Spinoza because I
actually don't think he's that important
when I'm carrying out the triage of
deciding what I want to fit in there
compared to some of the other figures
that I teach and the ethics is
interesting the you know the the
theological political treatise is also
interesting as well I don't buy any
Spinoza's conception of God or his
rejection of final causality or and you
know I know that my students find his
use of the geometrical mathematical
model just mind-boggling
I mean he's useful for looking at the
emotions I think the card is is probably
better in his passions of the soul but
you know or Aquinas and the treatise on
the emotions although he's he's a little
bit schematic with it but you know for
people who are into Spinoza it might be
good to go through a Spinoza phase where
you really try to think out the whole
world through that lens as a matter of
fact that's sort of something that's a
generalization that I think can work for
philosophy across the board as you're
developing it it's good to go through
phases where you you
read somebody and you read everything
that the person wrote obsessively and
try to think out the world through the
lens of their ideas and and see how it
works for you and see what what it
illuminates and what you run into you're
like well I can't really make this work
I can't fit this in there and then you
know you decide whether you want to keep
something from them or whether you want
to move on to somebody else and leave
them completely behind and sometimes
you'll you know you'll read somebody and
you spend a lot of time on them and then
you leave them aside for a long time and
then you'll come back to them later on
when you find that it's useful and
having done that groundwork ahead of
time can be really helpful let's see
Blackwood says nice shirt thanks yeah I
threw on one of the band shirts that
that fits well I have to get back to
exercising regularly I can tell that I'm
doing really well with it when all of my
band shirts fit good some of them are
bigger than others so mark says yoga and
weights great keep persisting in your
endeavors yeah I mean I don't do yoga
very often and I and one of the things
for this new year is I want to begin my
mornings by doing some stretching
because I'm getting less and less
flexible and so going to yoga classes
would probably help with that but man is
that is that when you're a beginner is
that a kick in the pants each time you
know as you try to do these things that
other people are easily executing so all
right um here's a good question for
Mohammed aren't some people stressed out
during holidays due to spending beyond
their means yeah and that that's a
that's a very common thing I think that
a lot of people mistake spending on
people or having just the the right
thoughtful gift or things like that as
something that's going to be a you know
incontrovertible expression of love it's
disappointing to see people like ripping
the the wrappings away and like moving
on to the next presence but those you
know those expectations unless you like
tell the person ahead of time listen
this is what I want from you and your
gift unwrapping activity it's really on
you for having those those ideas
governing your your spending habits and
expectations and those are you know that
actually be a great thing to do a little
writing about maybe I'll do a piece on
that not just about holidays but about
gift-giving in general and birthdays and
other other occasions where we give
people gifts or people who are involved
in romantic relationships and giving
each other gifts when if it's a genuine
gift you can't expect to control what
the other person is going to do by way
of reaction because then it's not really
a gift right it's a giving in order to
get it's it's more of a transaction but
yeah and the other thing that you've got
in that question is spending beyond
their means I think that our culture
really encourages us to spend beyond our
means most of the time but especially
over the holidays and again people
wrongly equate the amount of money spent
with the quality of the gift or the
intention behind the giving a friend of
mine and I did a whole radio show
recently about gift-giving generosity
and gratitude for a local radio station
here River West radio and you can you
can find that on my page or it's in my
Twitter stream
maybe I'll post about it later on today
as well so that's actually a really
great set of questions Lowell D's oodles
do you think that can't provide an
adequate critique of Spinoza
in the critique particularly the
antinomies you mean in the first
critique right yeah I mean it's been a
long time since I've read it so I would
have to go back to it as a matter of
fact it's been a while since I even
looked at the prolegomena where the
antinomies are discussed as well I mean
I don't know that cotton EADS to provide
a critique of Spinoza ISM Spinoza ISM as
such it's it's always just struck me as
so implausible you know although very
interesting I mean I think on strikes me
as implausible as well but I like
reading his critiques there there's
quite a few philosophical systems where
you can look at them and it almost an
aesthetic way and be like yeah that's
really cool probably not like that but
that's an interesting thing the way we
often look at fantasy worlds
all right Muhammad is importance of
routine and discipline what do you think
of liquid modernity I'm not sure what
liquid modernity means but I mean it
sounds interesting but Rutina discipline
is absolutely important you cannot get
much accomplished without it flights of
genius and inspiration those are cool
but you really can't build much upon
them you need something else the sort of
plotting through day by day by day stuff
and that that points to the importance
of whatever you want to call it the
Faculty of the will pro racists choice
that points to that ask but commitments
is another great way of translating
Croesus you really can't do much in the
realm of the mind without bringing in
the dimension of volition and
effectivity and the importance of habit
and routine and like you said discipline
asks cases so Blackwood says just went
through a pretty big Heidegger phase
well that's good Heidegger somebody
who's well worth reading and get a lot
out of him and that actually leads me to
a good other question from more ages
Maurice flow and I'll ever discuss
Heidegger in any of his works not that I
know of but interestingly Ernesto Grassi
was a student of Heidegger international
grassi's work is not particularly well
known he was an Italian writer who was a
student of Heidegger and now if you know
anything that Heidegger is said about
German and Greek as philosophical
languages and everybody else's is
basically crap you can well imagine one
of the preoccupations of Grassi which is
showing no Latin an Italian you know
that whole tradition is not just just
derivative d'etre to soar whatever and
Grassi was really attentive to the
importance of dialectic and rhetoric and
the classical tradition that goes all
the way back to Aristotle and Cicero and
people like that of combining philosophy
and rhetoric using dialectic as the
bridge for that and he saw in Vico a
resuscitation of that a rejection of the
modern obsession with epistemology
driving everything else and you know
sort of Cartesian clear and distinct
ideas and a recognition that
communication plays a major role in in
our thinking so now going back Graci at
one time went to blown-down and I think
this isn't like the late 30s or early
40s and told blown-down well maybe this
is the late 40s I guess it would make
more sense for it to happen after World
War two is resolved he told Blondell
that Heidegger had read blown Dells
stuff and wanted to communicate to him
that he thought it was quite interests
work I don't remember the source for
that unfortunately that's back when I
was actually like doing my dissertation
on Bluebell and I was reading grassy and
and I'd read Heidegger and I thought it
was kind of an interesting idea
Suren writes hoping to set help set up
Sheffield City Stoics in the next year I
must read up on the stoic network for
resources so you're you're referencing
the stoic fellowship I think there's a
worldwide organization called the stoic
fellowship and most of the smaller local
meetups or you know groups or things
like that not all of them are
necessarily using meetup itself are on
the they're like local stoechas we have
one here in Milwaukee so yeah there's a
lot of resources there that can be quite
helpful you know the most important
thing is just consistency doing it
monthly or bi-weekly or whenever you're
going to do it and you know making sure
that that people come in and you want to
be welcoming and when people you should
you know expect to answer the same
questions over and over and over again
which which is okay because that's how
people learn right we we've had ours
going I don't know if it's for two years
or for three years I think it's three
years now here in Milwaukee and and we
still get newcomers asking the same
questions and it's good to have you know
some people there is resources as little
hands
it's nice here that we've got quite a
few people so all right reverent
tangents suggestions on further reading
for the oolitic criticisms of the forms
I don't know that we actually have any
further reading on that because we don't
we don't have them you know and we don't
know whether the illy annex actually had
anything to say about Plato's conception
of the forms it could be that Parmenides
is just a character that Plato is using
to to you know introduce ideas in his
own works we don't know that the
Parmenides in xeno in dialogue
Parmenides are actually the historical
Parmenides and zeno so alright Tomac who
is how does reference across possible
worlds work you know I haven't looked at
a possible world semantic stuff since
graduate school other than you know
people using it in in analytic
philosophy articles that I'll read but I
haven't done any like groundwork in it
for a long time so I don't really know I
I would say the place to start it of
course is with David Lewis cuz he's the
one who started he's not of course the
person who came up with the notion of
possible worlds I mean live Nets brings
that in and actually it gets worked out
a lot in science fiction you know a then
we'll vote for example some of his
stories discussed that in considerable
detail and there's been others as well
but Louis in the I think his project
really got started in the 80s and it was
in full swing by the time I was in
graduate school in 90s he is he is the
person to go to Matt Olly Honda and
doctors say are you an atheist and
whether the answer is yes turn oh what
do you think about atheism in general
well I'll start with the second part
there is no such thing as atheism in
general any more than there is religion
in general there are all different kinds
of atheists there some were basically
like you know as religious as religious
believers the worst caricatures big
Crusaders there's others who just grew
up in a totally vacuum environment and
it never occurred to them that religion
could be anything interesting I had a
colleague like that when I was in
graduate school who's from Southern
California and just it just he couldn't
understand what all these religious
people were black and literally didn't
have a frame of reference and there was
people who are sort of questing and
there's people who have
who say that they're atheists but really
are despairing religious people so
there's all different kinds you know
there isn't really an atheist um in
general and and it's kind of interesting
because what the last five years have
shown us is that when you actually have
a like a worldwide atheist movement it
quickly fractures along all these lines
well what do we think about feminism
what do we think about anti feminism up
there's a split right how should we look
at the New Atheism all these these
groups have become very fragmented and
many of them quite toxic turning against
each other
am I an atheist no I'm not
but atheism in general really I think
there's a lot of people just like with
religion there's a lot of people who
take it on because not because of you
know like strict epistemological needs
and and reasoning or anything like that
but because it fulfills some emotional
demands for them I think the most
interesting kinds of atheists are the
ones who take religion seriously and are
puzzled by it and can finally
differentiate between different forms
like Lacan is is an atheist who says
that other than these sayings back in
like the 50s I think other atheists are
off based in the claims that they're
making he's essentially criticizing me
at the time equivalent to the new
atheist the new atheist so there's
nothing new about them at all they've
they they're just reincarnation of
previous atheists you know you can find
their sort of shtick and you know people
in the 40s or you know caricatures by
whether they're by other atheists like
George Bernard Shaw or by Christians
like Chesterton back in the you know
early teens and stuff like that there's
nothing new about about this this sort
of approach other than changing the
names a bit or are they going with that
also so yeah so let you know having
approaches to atheism that recognize the
centrality and importance
perhaps that there's some sort of
deep-seated desire and need for what it
is that religion is is providing also
say this the religious thinkers that I'm
always most interested in are those for
whom religion did not solve problems and
make their life easier but who for whom
religion made things more complex and in
some cases more difficult and
problematic and that includes all these
thinkers from you know from about the
the second century on Justin Martyr
Christianity did not like make
everything simple for him it actually
complicated things quite a bit all the
way into you know thinkers in the
nineteenth and twentieth century like
Sir and Kierkegaard or love chests off
or Chesterton you know all the way down
to the present so bkbk has an
interesting thing here I wonder if the
more Christmas becomes detached from its
religious meaning that the more
stressful it's become sometimes but I'll
tell you religious people can make it
stressful as hell as well you know they
pick the busiest time of the year to
have lots and lots and lots of pageants
and services and you know the the church
has to be decorated just right and the
choir better sing just right because all
the people who haven't been here you
know all year are gonna be flooding in
so I mean it can it can be stressful all
around you know we like after years and
years of stressing out over holidays in
in the Sandler shaaka household we like
to have holidays as low-key as possible
and you know just to enjoy ourselves and
get through them and you know take it
easy but I think a lot of people some
people actually like kind of get off on
making things complicated and stressful
and all that put them aside I think that
whether it's secular Christmas oriented
around
Santa Claus and reindeer and gift-giving
and all that other stuff or whether it's
you know the reason for the season
Christmas celebrating the the
incarnation of and the the Nativity of
God
you know intervening in history bringing
love into the world all those those
sorts of themes people have found ways
to turn it into something quite quite
stressful and convoluted so alright uh
Volkl Locke what do you think of anti
tech philosophers like Ted Kaczynski and
Jack Lew was the first time I've seen
somebody refer to Ted Kaczynski as a
philosopher but I suppose if you write a
long enough manifesto you know that
you've got a broad conception of
philosophy why not I haven't even read
Kozinski's manifesto so I can't really
say much about him a little I've read a
bit of and you know he makes some
interesting points I don't know that
there's that much it's not like we're
gonna ever go back unless some absolute
crisis happens to and I was tempted to
say pre technological but it's really
you know prelate industrial
technological point of view because you
know we've always had technology
language is a form of Technology and
agriculture you know all the things that
were so writes about in his pieces back
in the 1700s are forms of technology and
they they arise out of exploiting
potentials of the human being and human
mind in relation to its environment so
there's also technologies at the self as
well as we know so I don't I don't
really have that much to say about that
Jacob
thoughts on Dante are you a fan never
taught like comedy I've never taught
Dante I've never really been in a
situation where it would it would really
make sense to do that cuz I don't
usually teach literature classes I mean
I could see if I was doing something on
the afterlife and views of it that could
be an interesting thing to do I like
Dante I mean I don't know I don't know
anybody who doesn't when they actually
spend the time on on Dante but I haven't
I haven't had the time to read Dante for
quite a while but I remember enjoying it
so alright mark-ass are all your YouTube
videos gifts no they they have a
different function I mean they could
this is where it's good to make a
distinction between sort of like the
original intention of something and then
what what can come out of it almost in a
way analogous to mission creep right so
especially like my core concept videos
you know I've been shooting them to use
as aids in my my online classes for
quite a while and it just so happens
that they're also useful for a lot of
other people and in shooting them I I
know that to be the case and I know that
by putting them out there I mean I
derive a little bit of income from them
from advertising but you know it's it's
not a definitely not not enough to pay
for what a videographer would would
expect so I am kind of giving them away
but yeah I mean I guess in a sense they
they could be considered that but they
provide me something to you know most of
my client referrals come through
watching my videos I'd say all right
let's see you got a question here that
I'm not quite sure I understand from
Diogenes the cynic
what is the problem you had with ooo I
know you get asked a lot but you just
read a book by Herman and found it
interesting I don't know it oo is so or
witch Herman you're talking about Artie
Whitby did Epicurus create the problem
of evil definitely not framing something
doesn't mean being the only person to
talk about it I mean I think you can see
that being articulated in here and there
in discussions in ancient Greek tragedy
and I think if you look cross-cultural
you'll see the problem coming up as well
so firing in 13 what strong argument
could you give against Plato's
remembering the forms when they look at
the world what is the correct viewpoint
so you're saying you you want an
argument against Plato's conception of
knowledge as memory remembering right
and that when we look at things in the
world we kind of dimly grasp them in
relation to the forms that we saw before
I mean it's a fairly implausible account
to begin with there's a lot of moving
pieces and assumptions built in there
that you know plenty of people of
attacked one of the things that I think
is particularly difficult with Plato
that he never does a good job in
explaining is the status of the soul so
the forms are immortal and allow us to
recognize what a thing is so the soul is
what does the recognizing right and it
does so by it by relation to the forms
that it remembers completo never really
explains this and then the quest
as well as the soul itself a form no I
can't be because it's moving and it
changes over time
well then is the soul a thing in which
there's participation in a form of soul
well he never says that at any point so
that that's that's probably you know
enough to go at it I'd say Artie would
be Socrates says that he doesn't know
anything but if that statement was true
with MEPI knowledge socrates never said
he doesn't know anything
that's a miss miss construal based on
sort of like reading summaries rather
than actually looking at the texts
Socrates over and over and over again
and Platonic dialogues if you read
through them will get his opponents to
say well we know this right or we know
this that that whole notion of like
Socrates being you know wise because he
knows that he doesn't know you got to do
more than just like bring that up you
got to connect that to the whole web of
other things that he says and so you got
to contextualize it cross cobia any tips
for beginners beginners in philosophy
yeah
find something that you enjoy reading
and spend some time with that and don't
worry over much about like having to
like do things in the proper order or
you know impress anybody else and if
people you know come along and tell you
you're doing it wrong maybe they're
right but most of the time you can
afford to say what the hell do they know
you know including college professors a
lot of them have you know their own like
it's got to be done this way you know
like their approach to the great book
sort of thing a lot of great books
people are very intellectually rigid
unfortunately because that's the
opposite of what you see in the great
books right so right Edmund Burke what
do you think about Graham Harman and
object-oriented philosophy well I I got
to interact with him at one time I
didn't find his presentation I haven't
read his books I haven't found it didn't
find
presentation particularly interesting or
illuminating so I don't know that it's
actually worth my time to get into
because you know there's always fads
always new movements and you gotta ask
yourself when you're reading the history
of philosophy written from the
perspective of 2,500 you know the year
2500 is this gonna be like a footnote or
a chapter or like a whole section or
this will even be mentioned at all like
for example there Eddy and
deconstruction that's probably going to
be all the stuff that Dario is written
probably gonna be at best like in a
great you know like sort of like this
thick history of philosophy that'll be a
paragraph or two some other movements
like the phenomenological movement that
will probably be a whole chapter you
know I don't think object-oriented you
know philosophy there's some other words
for it speculative realism I think is
one of them I don't I just don't see it
sticking around anymore than radical
orthodoxy will or stuff like that
Roy roots does overspending during
holidays equal cognitive dissonance no
cognitive dissonance is when you've got
two concepts and you're trying to hold
them together in your mind they don't
fit and it's creating sort of an
effective response so over spending
during the holidays is an action mark
Trumble who's been reading pro CLIs is
the whole a third thing independent of
being in unity I don't know because I
haven't been reading Pro CLIs it's been
a long time since I've looked at that so
I I don't know that I can answer that
question
Oh Diogenes how do I counter the feeling
of pretentiousness in my philosophy
seminars things said seem quite vapid
and I can't escape saying things that
sound just as shallow and unnecessarily
convoluted uh you know maybe take a
little pressure off yourself
that that's something that that you do
go through I think but you know ideas
and and words are real things they are
they have being and you can explore them
and what seems to be superficial and
doll and vapid from one perspective may
turn out not to be so from another which
is often a later perspective it might be
good just to sit back and try to get as
much out of it as you can even though
you're not finding yourself like really
engaged with it all right
because it'll turn out sometimes that
you need like a certain critical mass of
stuff and then suddenly things click and
you're like whole now I get it that's
what they are up to there sir and what
is a dis preferred indifferent joking
well a dis preferred indifference as a
rejected indifference you know that's
what the Stoics called it Anthony asks
how would you characterize nerds
relations to Hegel and what about Pascal
so that's a that's a that's actually a
great question
Kierkegaard's relation to Hegel is not
just as a critic of Hegel as a matter of
fact he uses the you know notion of
dialectical all the time
sound as if Hegel had a complete
monopoly on that other German idealists
did as well and it's good to remember
that that Kierkegaard studied in Berlin
not with Hegel himself but but with
others you know at that time and I mean
if Hegel lived a bit longer maybe
Kierkegaard would have gotten to study
with him Kierkegaard has Kierkegaard
views hegel hegel himself as occupying
in you could say in modern philosophy
sort of the position that Socrates does
in ancient philosophy staking philosophy
and the ethical if we're using
Kierkegaard stage is about as far as
go and that's a good thing and there's
different levels of the ethical and you
know Hegel and and Socrates are at the
highest but they they just aren't able
Socrates doesn't have the opportunity of
taking into account the in you might say
the intrusion of God the eternal into
human time Hegel could but Hegel lapses
back into the ethical and turns religion
into a kind of philosophy so you know
that famous polemic in fear and
trembling that everybody takes faith in
something that you're starting from
rather than what you're working your way
to and the idea is to get past faith
well that that's straight out Hegel hey
galleons aren't as good as Hegel himself
and hey galleons were sort of the main
game in town one when Kierkegaard was
around so think about you know
derivative people derivative thinkers
who are like spouting Hegel maybe not
really understanding fully what they're
talking about and that's part of what
what Kierkegaard is reacting against
malt ball is it moti PI I'm applying to
Notre Dame's history of science and
philosophy PhD with a project proposal
on Barracks own basically saying
Einstein as a soul denying animist and
Esty Esty + qm is biopolitics any advice
nope
I mean good luck with the project I
don't know what Notre Dame's history of
science and philosophy program is like
you know I my my contacts with the
University of Notre Dame basically ended
when I left Indiana to move down to
North Carolina I used to go to their
their conferences that were held by the
center for ethics and culture quite
frequently and I worked briefly with
Mack and
but that department is a whole different
animal now you know I I don't know what
what they do Mohammed says how do you
see the impact of social media on people
and the information overload coupled
with focus on the negative news of the
media well we definitely live in a new
time you know we're in it we're in a
different environment right this is
something that my wife and I talk about
sometimes we we are Gen Xers we grew up
at the cuffs point between like
television radio computers coming in you
know they were there were computers in
our schools but they were you had to
take a computer class to use a computer
we saw the the development of integrated
systems and the rise of you know various
types of interesting software to do
these different things and eventually
the thing that we now call the Internet
and then the spread of mobile technology
we live through all of that you know the
notion of like Millennials being digital
natives that it's been pushed
basically by boomers educational experts
that was always [ __ ] the the real
there never was anything it's like a
digital native that you know as a matter
of fact I think Gen Xers as a generation
because we sort of grew into the
technology we actually understood it way
better than the generations coming after
it so we're constantly like showing my
kids who are you know Gen Z how things
work in in the technology that they know
because they don't know to look for it
so you know we've got this interesting
set of transformations that I think
speculative fiction can be very helpful
for helping us understand you know it
reminds me to have another thing
post-modernism is getting to be kind of
a dirty word these days the way that
liberal became in the 80s people you
know accusing people of it without
actually knowing
what it means and I was leading a client
recently through Jameson's big book
post-modernism the the cultural logic of
late capitalism which I hadn't read for
a while but as a if you want to actually
understand what post-modernism means you
should read that book all right can't
adequately criticize it or you know rail
against it unless you actually know what
post-modernism has meant and means and
Jameson talks about one way of defining
it as the realization that we're at the
point where nobody knows what the hell's
going on everybody's got all sorts of
great narratives and schemas and stuff
like that but when it comes to like the
vast panoramic thing nobody has their
head around the hole and the realization
that that's the case is one way of
understanding post-modernism and the
Internet is certainly contributed to
that I'd say I mean that book was
written before the proliferation of the
internet let alone mobile technology so
of course it would have to be you know
read done now but all right um by renn
again says if I heard of
presuppositional apologetics what are my
thoughts on it I'm not big on
apologetics to begin with I certainly
you know looked at plenty of that stuff
back in the day I agree with Maurice
Blondell in his letter on apologetics
that any real effective apologetic would
have to be very different than the
schematic [ __ ] that people tend to
put forward if I remember right why I
can't even remember exactly what what
Protestants mean by priests off of
presuppositional apologetics I think
it's it if I remember right it's the
stuff that's kind of associated with
these Calvinist thinkers but I don't
want to speculate about it so I don't
have any real thoughts all right um bar
Canon have you read any Buddhist
philosophy yeah I started reading
Buddhist stuff back in my teens and
continued through and taught classes on
while not direct not just on Buddhism
but on what we at that time we're
calling Eastern or non-western
philosophy in my first job and I
continued reading stuff about it here
and there and I actually having to have
some Buddhist in my family who are
actually Pure Land Buddhists which is
very different than the largely zan and
smattering of Tibetan Buddhist that most
Americans get exposed to but it's a very
important school so yeah I've been I've
been reading Buddhist stuff for quite a
while will hearing would you say
Kierkegaard was a monist or a duelist
neither let's say he's a pluralist all
right just jump to little bits mark says
holidays are for sleep working out and
study a good way to do it yeah made of
clay what are some things you really
don't like about philosophy well about
philosophy as such I don't really have
anything I don't like about philosophy
about academic philosophy I would say
you know the question I forget who asked
it earlier about the pretentiousness
there's we have a joke that has been
going around for a long time why are the
disputes in philosophy departments so
bitter and the answer is because the
stakes are so low so people get really
really really worked up over minor
things and they they should you know
they should treat each other as human
beings and realize that we're on a sort
of shared path of understanding things
you guys are almost like doing stage
whisper over there my kids are trying to
keep quiet while I'm doing this but not
succeeding so
yeah I would say that the way in which
we teach philosophy and maybe also I
could complain about I mean I should
complain about the way we share
knowledge and philosophy in academic
philosophy which is through publishing
houses that make a ton of money on our
articles charge library's vast sums pay
people very little if anything for the
labor that they put into it and by the
by the people I mean the editor is not
not the reviewers not the writers or
anything like that that's all crap you
know that's a terrible thing but you
know the way in which we organize the
way how we teach it
it is quite bad to I mean we're shackled
to the 15 week semester here in the
United States we can't get away from
that so if you want to get accreditation
you have to do things in that way I mean
you can switch it up and like say we're
going to do 15 weeks worth of stuff in
eight weeks right but it's still the
same basic units and so we have to do
this this crazy like triage and we have
a lot of people teaching philosophy who
don't really want to teach philosophy we
have a lot of people who would be great
teachers who are shut out for one reason
or another you know the prestige of the
institution they got their degree from
we we allow the elite universities who
churn out lots of graduates just like
everybody else to effectively dominate
the job market even though you know
there's no evidence at all that anybody
come in from an elite university got any
better education or teacher training or
anything than the other places so so
academic philosophy is really quite a
mess
but philosophy as such is going to
continue on through the millennia and
you know it really anytime that you look
at things you can find some things that
you you would complain about
marsden have other philosophers debunked
ernst Bester's denial of death or terror
management theory I'm not even sure what
that is so you know I can't really say I
don't know terror management theory is
Matt chimed in and said good job keep it
up
Thanks that that's that's very nice man
is laughing over there oh wow okay Sarah
asks a really great question here what
is the meta skill that can be acquired
by studying philosophy to argue
correctly and become a new out more
nuanced thinker is there a shortcut to
the meta level so there are no shortcuts
in philosophy period you either do the
work or you don't
Kierkegaard is a great discussion of
this in the life of the Spirit in
beginning of fear and trembling the meta
skill that's acquired by studying
philosophy a lot of people will say yeah
it's like critical thinking or
argumentation and that's that's true to
some degree but it's not as if that's
exclusive to philosophy and a lot of
ways that philosophies do our
philosophers argue is actually not
particularly helpful when you have to
interact with ordinary people or people
in the other disciplines I think that
the most important skill that you learn
or don't learn depending on how you do
things in philosophy is making
distinctions well being able to say
you're looking at this thing as if it's
just one thing when we can look at it
from multiple points of view and looking
at it from those multiple points of view
leads us to different conclusions so as
you see argumentation or inference is
involved in that but it's being able to
make the distinction and I have had so
many experiences in dealing with
business people and in dealing with
academics and other disciplines and in
dealing with ordinary people and and
dealing with psychologists I can go on
and on and on where we're having a
discussion and people
get confused about something or get to
get into an argument and then I say whoa
whoa hey what we're looking at here is
this but this can mean two different
things and if you mean this well then
this follows from that if you mean this
this follows from that you're gonna look
at it you know differently depending on
which which handle you pick it up from
to use epictetus framework right and
people think that's magic they're like
holy crap Wow
and and then afterwards you know you
give him a little bit of time they're
like wow I could have made that
distinction myself and then you're like
well yeah but you didn't because you
weren't used to making distinctions now
this can go too far as a matter of fact
one of the things that you see as a
constant complaint and a legitimate
complaint is these philosophers make too
many distinctions you want a distinction
that as Plato says cuts the the the you
know the thing at the joints cuts
reality at the joints rather than at the
bone or something like that
well that's you know that's I would say
that's the meta skill oscar asks where
do you begin with Hegel so I would
actually suggest beginning with two
lectures that sound very similar
lectures on the philosophy of history
lectures on the history of philosophy
and then only after that go and read the
phenomenology but everybody always
begins with the phenomenology because
they see it everywhere that's why I did
the you know half hour Hegel project all
right um
I'm gonna have to end pretty soon
because I'm gonna have to go to shut up
and write and just a few let's see here
Daniel Cox do you endorse divine
impassibility simplicity analogy of
being yeah as a matter of fact my my
first paid speaking gig was at st.
Anselm's College the st. Anselm lecture
which you can find the transcript of
so I just read you know the thing in my
academia.edu perfectly simple God and
are complicated moral life divine
simplicity is not the simplicity of
simple things in this this realm it's
you could call it hyper simplicity so
yeah I endorse that the analogy of being
it depends on what you mean by it you
know different different thinkers have
used that that term differently I do
think that that being cannot be
understood in a in a purely equivocal
way dyad Jeanine is any quick tips on
how to quickly break down readings for
classes I've been given the entire
ethics of ambiguity and not sure what to
highlight as significant well I mean the
good thing is that's a pretty
straightforward book and it's pretty
short I would say in that case you know
you want to talk about the the different
ways in which people misuse their
freedom and that's in parts 1 and 2 of
that and then talk about you know what
de Beauvoir figures as the right use of
our freedom which involves necessarily a
connection with the freedom of others
and I think one of the key things you
want to highlight with that work is that
de Beauvoir much more than Sartre
acknowledges how some people might not
have the sort of radical freedom that
that Sartre figures them as as having
because of their their economic
political social family whatever sort of
dynamics has been holding them back from
from development but yeah tips for how
to quickly break down readings I don't
have tips for that sort of thing
I think that I need just go at it and do
do your best
I don't know that you want to quick
quickly breakdown
readings but yeah alright um it's soon
Ibaka I know this is silly but I trust
your advice on it I'm in love with
someone but it's unrequited how do I
move on that's difficult
maybe not putting too much pressure on
yourself to move on right away it's okay
to feel sad and disappointed about
unrequited love happens to people all
the time and it's happened throughout
history but it's the sort of thing that
you you know now that you know that
you're suffering from it you don't want
to draw any conclusions from that global
conclusions about you know whether
you'll ever meet somebody or anything
like that you want to sort of insulate
it from all all your other things that
are going on and eventually it'll it'll
go away you'll you'll meet somebody else
and feel those sorts of things again
alright cyber count any textbook
recommendations for teaching a
first-year undergrad history of ethics
course that's on McIntyre's history of
ethics well I like MacIntyre a lot his
history of ethics pretty good it's
definitely got its you know a MacIntyre
it takes we probably would want to
explain what McIntyre's overall projects
are I actually have my undergraduates
read primary text when it comes to the
history of ethics I don't use anthology
I provide them with the texts and I
usually kind of go I used to start out
with like Plato and Republic and I would
bring in a couple other you know
thinkers to supplement so we've got like
you know an authoritarian attitude
towards ethics with through Simek is so
sometimes I bring in nature sometimes I
bring in you know a bit of Hobbes and
then like you know
Glaucon proposes something like a social
contract theories while bringing some
Hobbes right there
you know and then we get virtue ethics
coming in and then I'd start doing
things in order but there's you know
there's no simple way to do it so all
right well then I think let me see here
well things are not working completely
right with the scrolling on this but
that's a good place to end the stream
it's 11 o'clock now so I got a gather up
my kids and head off to shut up and
write and hope everybody has a good
holidays well we got a lot of cool stuff
coming up this next month and this next
year but I'll I'll do another little
talk about that closer to the new year
and maybe I'll do another stream on a
New Year Eve or New Year's Day we'll see
about that as well so all right I'll see
all of you have a great whatever it is
evening afternoon morning late nights
whatever you're doing